for many of us this was a routine
childhood experience but now vaccination
rates for British children have been
falling for four years in a row amid a
mixture of complacency misinformation
and skepticism the health secretary is
considering a drastic change to bring
those rates back up again I don't want
to see compulsory vaccination and I
don't think we're there yet but I've
said that we rule nothing out because
vaccination saves lives and the fall in
the rates of vaccination has to has to
stop because the science is absolutely
clear and it's settled
which is that vaccination is the right
thing to do at the roald dahl museum in
great miss ndon we've been given access
to this letter that the author wrote
about his seven-year-old daughter olivia
who died from measles before a reliable
vaccine was available 24 years after
Olivia's death Roald Dahl wrote a letter
urging all parents to get their children
vaccinated against measles he said I was
unable to do that for Olivia in 1962
because in those days a reliable vaccine
had not been discovered but here at the
museum dedicated to his memory there are
mixed feelings among parents about
compulsory vaccination when it comes to
vaccinations in the long run it's going
to save them the the National Health
Service money because it's going to
prevent illnesses in the future I'd just
like some more information so that I
know that I've made the right choice my
children sort of know the long-term
implications of using immunization
compared to actually using uranium in
the system to build its own defenses
ultimately the parents with the health
authorities I think should should be
able to make a decision together last
year nearly a thousand cases of measles
were recorded in England nearly four
times as many as in 2017 over half a
million UK children missed out on the
MMR vaccine between 2010 and 2017 and
nearly 40,000 British parents have
joined an online group calling for
children to be left unamused in all 50
US states children must be vaccinated in
order to attend school with some
religious exemptions but despite the
complete discrediting of a two decade
old study linking one
vaccine with autism there's a growing
backlash against that law and some are
concerned that making vaccination
compulsory could have that effect here -
I think it just raises the level of
anxiety and concern around these sort of
issues when we need a calm climate in
which nurses and health visitors and
doctors can discuss these matters calmly
with parents and reassure them over
their anxieties about vaccinations which
have been raised by publicity over the
last few years
roald dahl wrote approvingly of
America's compulsory system the health
Secretary's decision on whether to
replicate it here could make all the
difference to these children's futures
Molly Shattuck Sky News